after almost 20 years a new matrix movie
is finally coming to theaters and set to
blow us all away who's back from the
original films and who's set to join the
casters new faces are you beginning to
believe
when the news of a fourth matrix movie
broken variety in august 2019 producer
and distributor warner brothers didn't
announce a release date for the film it
did say that production was scheduled to
begin sometime in early 2020. in
december of 2019 warner brothers
announced a matrix iv release date of
may 21st 2021
unlike the matrix and the matrix
reloaded which hit theaters in late
march 1999 and mid-may 2003 respectively
the fourth matrix won't see a spring
release or even an awesome one like the
matrix revolutions which made its way to
theaters in november 2003. further
hollywood reporter filming on the matrix
resurrections was paused in march 2020
over coronavirus spread concerns and one
of brothers accounted for that delay by
pushing the scheduled release to april
2022 about six months later with
production picking up warner moved up
the release date to december 22nd 2021
the same day the matrix resurrection
said theaters it'll also be available to
stream for subscribers of hbo max for a
limited time i want it come on give me
it give me it give me it
come on give me it
the special effects might have felt like
the real stars of the matrix and its
sequels but those films wouldn't have
been nearly as good or as memorable if
the human actors hadn't pulled their
weight keanu reeves proved his action
hero turn in speed wasn't a fluke with
his role as neo carrie anne moss at the
time of the release of the matrix in
1999 was a little-known talent with a
bunch of episodic television credits to
her name but the matrix made her a star
reeves and moss quickly locked in their
commitment to return to play neo in
trinity one actor who definitely won't
be back hugo weaving due to a scheduling
conflict he's not available to reprise
his role as the villainous agent smith
lots of other big names played central
roles in the matrix trilogy like
lawrence fishburne and jada pinkett
smith fishburne won't reprise his role
but pinkett smith will along with
lambert wilson who played the merrow
vinjian and daniel bernhardt who played
agent johnson
in october 2019 the cast of the matrix
resurrections started to take shape neal
patrick harris landed a role that the
film's trailer indicated was a therapist
of some sort harris is primarily a tv
performer best known for his work on how
i met your mother and doogie hauser md
and the matrix resurrections will mark
his biggest movie yet writer director
producer lana wachowski saw several
actors for another secret part in the
matrix resurrections later revealed to
be a character called morpheus the
original morpheus was made famous by
lawrence fishburne in the original
matrix trilogy the right man to possibly
replace fish burn for the job yaya abdul
mateen ii a rising star thanks to his
scene-stealing performance in the
get-down and his work in hbo's watchmen
mini-series another new member of the
matrix family priyanka chopra according
to variety in january 2020 the quantico
star underwent fight training for weeks
in anticipation of the film beginning
production
in 2021 a korean matrix resurrection
poster divulged that chopra is playing
the adult version of sati the child that
the oracle was taken care of in 2003's
the matrix revolutions fans speculate
that sarti may be the new oracle in the
matrix resurrections but we still don't
know for sure brian j smith and aaron
deera obara best known for their work on
the wachowski's netflix series sense8
will also appear in the matrix
resurrections as with jessica henwick
christina ricci jonathan groff and telma
hopkins
would it really be a matrix movie if
lana and lily wachowski weren't involved
after turning heads with the stylish
1996 crime drama bound the wachowskis
made themselves legends with the matrix
in 1999 unveiling a novel premise set in
a marvelously realized universe the
siblings co-wrote and co-directed the
matrix the matrix reloaded and the
matrix revolutions but the reports
announcing the matrix resurrections
don't note the involvement of lilly
witchowski lana wachowski is evidently
going low this time around wachowski
won't have to go it totally alone
however she'll direct from a script
co-written with literary figure
alexander hermann and david mitchell who
both wrote an episode of the rochowski's
sense8 while mitchell wrote cloud atlas
turned into a film by the wachowskis in
2012 john toll meanwhile will handle the
cinematography he previously shot
jupiter ascending and cloud atlas for
wachowski and won academy awards for his
work on legends of the fall and
braveheart
prominently and suspiciously not
mentioned anywhere in varieties august
2019 report about the launch of a then
entitled fourth movie in the matrix
series was a key character known as
morpheus nobody said anything about
whether the mental figure would return
for the new movie or not nor was there
any mention of the involvement of
lawrence fishburne the actor who played
the part in the original three movies
not to worry saves variety reporter
justin krull shortly after he published
a story about the matrix iv he tweeted
sources have told me this may point to
where and when the film is set as i have
heard execs are looking a variety of
actors to possibly play him and that's
about all we know about the plot the
fact that morpheus looks to be played by
yaya abdomen team ii suggests the matrix
resurrections takes place in a different
time than the original trilogy morpheus
was killed off in the matrix online an
mmo rpg that continued the story from
the original trilogy but whether the
game's events are still considered canon
is unknown perhaps mateen ii is playing
a digital version of morpheus based on a
younger mind or is mateen the second's
character simply inspired by morpheus
what do you think is happening right now
guys it doesn't matter it's good you
know we'll sort this out later it
doesn't matter
the news of the new matrix movie with
most of the original cast and creators
means that a different matrix based
product is likely no longer happening in
march 2017 the hollywood reporter broke
the news that warner brothers had
started preliminary development of a
reboot relaunch of the matrix
screenwriter zac penn who wrote x-men
the last stand and ready player 1 was
reportedly in talks to write a detailed
narrative plot outline all because
original matrix producer joel silva
approached warner brothers with the
suggestion of a revival noachowskis were
not involved with that project and no
actors signed up to star although
initial reports hinted that warner
brothers would have liked to cast
michael b jordan aslano wachowski keanu
reeves and carrier moss all returned to
make the matrix resurrections this other
new matrix is now old news perhaps
that's for the best
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]